- You're Billy Dee Williams.
- [Airline Worker] Jason Schwar.
- Allison Janney.
- That's great.
- Ah, ah, ah, ah!
- Dicknanigans.
- All right.
(feel good music)
♪ All I want, yeah ♪
♪ But I don't need you ♪
- Six-time Emmy Award
winner, Allison Janney,
will light up your TV screens
later this week,
in a brand new mini series.
What happens when a frontier won
riding the trail
learns her father is an Apache ?
That's "Wagons", a nine-part mi,
coming up later this week,
on CCN Family.
- I know I'm gon' be
watching that one. (laughs)
- Oh yeah.
- Trip the light fantastic,
when "West Wing" star, Allison ,
makes her debut on Star Dancing.
Don't miss Allison
as she tangos her way into your.
That's next week, on CCN.
Check your local listings.
- Allison Janney,
who stars in a "Haunting on 4th,
a supernatural thriller
you won't wanna miss.
Alison Janney plays a woman
who was possessed by a demon,
that is also possessed
by a different demon.
- That's double up! (laughs)
- Viewer discretion is advised.
- Coming soon!
Allison Janney stars as Fran,
a woman who means to visit
her nephew for Thanksgiving,
but she drives to a small
town she's never been to
while in a trance.
10 years ago, in the same town,
Cathy, who looked just like Fra,
was murdered.
(tense music)
The town assumed that
Cathy's boyfriend, Arthur,
who went missing at the
same time as the murder,
had done it.
But, Fran starts having multiple
dream sequences and trances
that reveal that something else.
(tense music continues)
Gradually, through investigatio,
and with the guidance of more v,
Fran uncovers the story behind s
and that she was, in fact, the .
(axe hits wall)
(tense music)
- Was that all on the prompter?
- Yeah, the whole twist
ending and everything.
- Oh, man.
I mean, why watch the show?
- All right.
- Oh, she's here, she's here.
(ominous music)
- Tonight,
Alison Janney is a former actres
who was made Queen Mother of Al,
when the computer graphic, know,
ascended to a stage of self-awa.
The digital deity, Queen Janney,
now presides over the cyber rea,
while her mechanical
minions heard and control
the last remnants of the
plague that was once humankind.
That's tonight,
and for the rest of time.
This has been today's mandatory.
(message echos)
- All hail Queen Allison Janney.
(dramatic sound)
- You showin' me out, son?
Now you gon' end up with a
bullet in your head for it.
- You can't play me, mother (be.
(tense music swells)
I'm the mother(beep)
that plays mother(beep),
mother(beep).
(dramatic music ends)
- [Director] Cut.
(bell rings)
- [Producer] All right, every b,
let's get reset,
we are going again.
- Nigel,
that's great.
- Oh, great,
it's smashing.
Thank you so much.
Yeah, well,
it's been an absolute honor
and what a great opportunity toe
and be able to play an American.
- Wow.
I'm just so glad
that we got you out of
that BBC commitment,
so you can play with us, so. (l)
- Cheers, mate.
Cheers, cheers.
- Antoine, listen,
I'm just not buying
that you're someone
that was born and raised
in the streets of Brooklyn.
- That's weird
'cause I actually was born and d
on the streets of Brooklyn.
(film crew shuffling)
I was in a gang and everything.
Most of this stuff
actually happened to me.
- Wow, okay.
Well, that's, that's,
that's great for us
'cause I want you to use it.
Okay?
Good first take.
Let's just uh, let's get going.
Let's get going.
- Thank you, Jim.
- Scene five, take two.
(claps clapperboard)
(bell rings)
- [Director] And action!
(tense music)
- You showin' me out, son?
Now you gon' end up with a
bullet in your head for it.
- You can't play me, mother(bee.
I'm the mother(beep)
that plays mother(beep),
mother(beep).
(tense music swells)
- (sighs) Cut.
(bell rings)
Cut.
(clears throat) Okay, Nigel,
that was great.
- Oh, brilliant.
- Just the way you move.
Especially, when you talk,
I just really see this character
coming to life before my eyes.
Just fabulous.
- Cheers, mate.
Cheers.
- It's fabulous.
Antoine, your performance, um,
it's just not quite there yet,
okay?
I really need to see you
make more of a transformation,
okay?
Like, like Nigel here.
- That dude's British.
- Yeah.
- Antoine, if I might jump
in with a bit of advice-
- I don't think I need that.
- No, no, no, no.
Here him out.
- Maybe,
you might want to try thinking
of something in the material
that's similar to something
that's happened in your real li.
- Mmm.
- For me, for instance,
I like to think of when (laughsm
wanted me to attend prep schools
to become a barrister,
but I wanted to study
the theater at Oxford.
- Thank God.
- And so, that was a
conundrum, really, for me.
- I'm gonna stop you right, rige
'cause it's just confusin' me.
Right?
Like, I don't need that
'cause I am from the streets.
I was in a gang.
They told me to kill my cousin.
- That might be a bit spot on.
No?
- Yeah, it's a bit spot on.
Do you have any stories
that involve your Mum?
- What's a Mum?
- Oh, dear.
- Scene five, take three.
(claps clapperboard)
(bell rings)
- Okay.
Antoine, remember you're a gang,
okay!
Betrayal, the streets!
Okay, Nigel, you're perfect!
Antoine, transform!
And action!
(tense music)
- You sold me out, son.
Now you gon' get a bullet
up in your head for it.
- You can't play me, mother(bee.
I'm the mother(beep)
that plays mother(beeps),
mother(beep).
(tense music swells)
- He's boring to watch.
(sighs) Cut!
(bell rings)
- Uh, that does not sound good.
- (sighs frustratingly) Antoine,
I do not feel like you have
found the emotional core
of this character!
- Man, (beep) this!
Nobody is more real than me,
okay?
I come from the streets,
and nobody's gon' tell me
what the streets is like,
nobody!
You understand?!
(film crew shuffling)
- That's a great speech,
I just wished that I believed i.
You wanna give it a shot?
- Sure, I'll have a go.
Man, (beep) this!
I'm as real as it gets!
- Yes.
- This (beep) streets is for re,
I'ma be in there, man.
- You are.
- I'm (beep) from the, from the,
from the Earth, from these stre.
- From the Earth-
- Something to that effect.
- No, but I'm so with you,
I'm with you when you say that,
even when you're saying the wro!
I just wish you could do that!
- You know what?
(gut punches Director)
(Director coughing)
- Oh, goodness.
- Okay, that hurts,
but I don't feel
that it comes from the
right emotional place
for the character,
all right?
Here, give it a shot,
Give me...
Watch, watch.
(gut punches Director)
(Director coughing)
- That's, that's great.
I feel that in here
and in here-
- That's very gracious of you,
to say that.
- In my heart.
Try that again.
(gut punches Director)
(Director coughing)
I just, I don't, (struggling to)
I don't believe you.
- I'm gonna go wash my hands.
- Oh, okay, sweetie.
See you soon.
(car honks)
(car passing by)
- (laughs) Buddy!
- Um, I'm sorry,
uh, that seat is actually taken.
My girlfriend is in the bathroom
and she should be back any seco,
so you cannot sit there.
- You don't even recognize me,
do you?
- No.
No, I don't,
I don't, I don't know you.
- We were in the "Human
Centipede" together!
- I said,
I do not know you.
- Three years ago,
we were kidnapped by the
crazy German scientist
who surgically connected us
into a single human digestive c.
There were three of us.
I was in the middle,
you were at the end,
the other guy was up front.
Your mouth was sewn to my butt !
- Okay, yes,
I remember.
And after years of therapy,
I finally put that behind me!
- Probably should have
said you put it behind me,
if you catch my drift.
(laughs) I'm sorry.
I'm sorry!
You already caught my drift.
I'm sorry! (laughs)
That's it.
It was right there in front of .
(laughs) I'm sorry.
- Really?
- I guess it was right
there in front of you.
That's it.
(laughs) I'm sorry.
How are you doin'?!
(laughs) How are you?
- Is there's something
else I can help you with?
- Um...
- Hey, (beep)eater.
- No (beep) way!
Front man! (laughs)
- This is a (beep) nightmare!
- Hey, back man.
Back man.
- No, don't call me that.
- Hey, cop a squat!
- No!
- Ooo, chili,
old habits die hard. (laughs)
- (laughs) Nice one.
- Now I can't eat it.
- Word.
- Why are you happy to see him?
- Come on, man.
You know,
we all shared the same experien.
- No, we didn't!
He was in the front,
nobody (beep) in his mouth!
- That is true.
- Do you ever stop eating,
ever?
- Only when I'm (beep).
- Okay.
- Well, but,
me and you,
right?
- Me and you what?
- I mean,
we were in the same boat.
- Nope!
You two were in the same boat.
You both (beep) in someone's mo!
I didn't get to (beep) in anyon!
- "Get to"?
- When do I get to (beep)
in anybody's mouth, huh?!
When do I get to (beep)
in somebody's mouth?!
- Steven?
- Hon, I know...
These, these guys...
I can explain this, I can expla.
(heels clicking)
Oh, you're disgusted?
You...
Oh, now you're gonna leave?
(laughs) Oh, yeah, that's great.
Oh, yeah.
Once again,
I'm the asshole.
All right,
(party music)
so that's just working easily t.
Okay, good, good.
Good, good, good.
(door closes)
- That's awesome, man.
- Okay, we gotta hurry up.
Break out the weed.
- I'm gonna get out there.
(lighter flicks)
- Hey.
(terrifying music)
- Oh, sorry, sorry.
- Ooh.
- Y'all want to do some of that?
(terrifying music continues)
(exhales creepily)
- No.
- What the (beep)?
Who's this guy?
- Y'all ever heard of the God d?
- Well,
I've, I've never heard of that.
- Aka slayer,
cutty cutty,
double cutty,
Elmo,
cat vag,
Long Island brain slice,
Funt.
- Funt?
- [Creepy Dude] Funt.
I've heard of that.
- It takes all of your
greatest fears and insecurities
and it gives them teeth and arm,
(horrifying tones)
and then it locks you
in the room with them,
from which you cannot escape.
(horrifying tones continue)
- Well, that sounds terrible.
- Yeah, I don't want that.
- None of those words are good.
- You'll realize the face of God
is somewhere inside your body,
but you can't find it,
and it hates you.
(voices echoing)
- Um, okay,
none of us are interested in th.
Thank you, sir.
Um, nice meeting you.
- Let's hear him out,
let's hear him out.
- It's a razor sharp crystal
you tuck under your eyelid.
(sparkling sound)
- Ooo.
- Ugh.
- Uh.
- And then,
when your ocular cavity starts ,
it goes directly into your brai.
- I feel like there's
gotta be a good part.
- Yeah.
You've just described a
life-wrecking physical addictio.
- Well, if you'd let him finish,
if you'd let him finish,
he's gonna get to the euphoria,
I'm sure.
- Just when you can take any mo,
(sucking through teeth)
you poop your mouth.
- I'm sorry, what?
- You poop in your mouth?
- No.
You poop outta your mouth.
- I'm in.
- Dude, Kev, come on man.
- [Friend On Right] No, don't.
- Guys,
if people are willing to go thr,
the high must be amazing.
- Uh, buddy,
remember when you did mushrooms
and you cried for three hours?
This is worse than that.
- Yeah.
- Oh!
(shoving crystal into eye)
Oh! Oh! Oh! Oh!
(falling onto ground)
(pulls curtains down)
Ah!
- Oh!
- [Drugged Out Friend] Oh, that!
Oh, that hurts!
- Oh, God.
- When does it start working?!
- How should I know?
I don't do drugs.
(horrifying music ends)
Drugs are for losers.
(upbeat music)
- There's no way that he can wi.
- No.
Mm-mm, no.
- So, anyway,
what'd you think of the season
finale of "Game of Thrones"?
- (gasps) Right!
- Oh, no, no, no, no,
no, no, no, no, no, no,
no, no, no.
I'm reading the books.
- Oh!
- Oh,
sorry, sorry, sorry, sorry.
- I'm reading the first book.
- And he reads slow.
(everyone laughs)
- We could never talk about it.
- You in trouble.
- We're never gonna talk about .
- Okay.
- [Woman With Bangs] No, you're.
- Hey,
has anybody seen that new
Russell Crowe thriller
'cause let me tell you-
- Ah, ah, ah!
Ah.
Sorry, it's just we're goin' tow
and I don't wanna know a thing .
- She doesn't wanna know a thin.
- Gotcha.
Okay, all right.
- Sure, yeah. (laughs)
- Yeah, you know how to (zips m.
- Yeah.
- [Woman In Patterns] So good, .
- Who won the game?
- I think that it was-
- No, no, no, no, no, no, no,
no, no, no.
That, I'm,
I'ma watch it later.
- Oh, you're-
- Oh, you have a DVR.
- I got it.
- Sorry, okay.
Mums the word.
- [Woman In Patterns] Yeah. (la)
- [Man In Patterns] So good.
- So.
- Yeah.
- What's the weather gonna be l-
- Ah, ah, ah, ah!
(dog barking)
Sorry, it's uh...
(sighs) We're having a
barbecue this weekend
and I don't want to
stress about the weather.
- [Man In Khaki] No, of course .
- We just, yeah...
- Yeah, you know, (mumbles).
(Woman with Bangs clears throat)
(crickets chirping)
(cutlery clinking)
- This three bean casserole is .
- Scooby-doo, boppa debop, bop,!
I'm so sorry, babe.
I just, I hadn't tasted them ye-
- I'm sorry.
I'm sorry.
- I'm really looking forward to.
You know?
- Don't talk about the
ingredients, I know.
- It's a surprise for your mout.
- [Woman In Patterns] Yeah.
- [Woman With Bangs] I like tha.
(cutlery clinking)
(sipping drink)
- Oh, uh... (laughs)
If you guys,
you know that commercial with...
If you didn't, okay...
No, it's not a (mumbles).
- Oh, no?
(crickets chirping)
- (laughs) Okay.
Eh, just...
(crickets chirping)
- Okay.
- [Woman In Patterns] Nevermind.
- It's probably best.
- Yeah, you don't wanna...
Yeah. (clears throat)
(crickets chirping)
- Oh, it...
No, it's fine.
No.
(sucks teeth)
- Cheesecake.
(Woman with Bangs gasps)
- What?
- [Woman In Patterns] Huh?
- We got cheesecake.
(crickets chirping)
I mean...
- Oh, yeah.
No, I,
I'd love some cheesecake.
Let's do that.
- Yeah.
- Yeah, all right.
(crosstalk about cheesecake)
I mean, I've been watching
my cholesterol intake,
but what the Hell, right?
(Woman in Patterns laughs)
We're all gonna die
someday, anyway, right?
(crickets chirping)
- What!?
- Honey!
- Wow!
- Are you kidding me?
- Come on, really?
- You just ruin it, every time!
I'll see you at home.
- Well, wait a second!
- So rude!
- Now, how would you not know
that that was taking place?!
(tense music)
(keyboard typing)
(footsteps clicking)
(door bell rings)
(door opens)
- Heil Hitler.
My name is Colonel Hans Mueller
of the SS.
As you know,
we were combing his area for Je.
But, it has come to our attentin
that two Negroes have escaped
and are hiding out in this area.
You wouldn't happen to
know anything about this,
now would you?
(crickets chirping)
- Uh, no!
No Negroes here.
- Uh, Negros?
Ew.
(both laughing)
Hell, no.
- And what are your names?
- Leroy...
Heimer.
Leroy-Heimer is my last name.
And my first name is very Germa,
and that is because it is Heinr.
So, my name is Heinrich Leroy-H.
- And I am Baron Helmut
(dog barking)
Schnitzel-Nazi.
- Well,
are you going to invite me in?
- Yes!
- Of course!
- Yeah, yeah, come on in.
Yeah, yeah, yeah, yeah.
Absolutely.
(footsteps clunking)
(solemn music)
- Please, gentlemen,
sit down.
Now,
as you know,
the Negro,
not unlike the Jew,
can be a very tricky creature.
(jingling cutlery)
Oh, that's fun.
We have developed many tests
to determine if an individual i,
an actual Negro.
(fire crackling)
It's very scientific,
like when we throw the beans
up against the homosexuals
to see if the beans explode.
(fire crackling)
- Yeah.
Uh, what kind of tests?
- It's interesting that
you would ask me that.
Would you mind
if I removed your hat?!
(dramatic sound)
So that I can measure your head.
The Negro head, interestingly e,
only comes in the half sizes.
It's one of the many interestins
about the Negro head.
Hmm.
Everything seems seem in order.
(Man in Suspenders exhales than)
- Well, no one Negro heads here!
- I tell you what, though.
If a Negro head came in here,
it would find itself detached
from it's Negro body!
I tell you that right here. (la)
Am I right?
- Yes, it's very, very good.
But, there are so many
exceptions to the rule,
which is why it's so important
that we have a test which is fo.
(dramatic music)
- Uh, m- m- more tests?
- You know,
hunting the Negroes all day,
you really build up an appetite,
you know what I'm saying?
(dramatic music continues)
Can I entrust your two
in some delicious beets?
(dramatic sound)
(footsteps clicking)
Interesting,
the Negro cannot resist the bee.
It is drawn to it like flies to.
(fire crackling)
Well, gentlemen,
it appears I have wasted your t.
(puts tray down)
(claps hands) I'll be on my way.
- Okay-
- Just one more thing.
I'm curious as to how you feel
about this cat toy!
(dramatic sound)
Jiggledy-diggledy!
(cat toy jingling)
Nothing?
Well, that's embarrassing.
(puts cat toy down)
I'm sorry for bothering you. (s)
You two are obviously not Negro.
(both laughing)
- Yeah.
Of course we're not Negroes.
- This is a no-Negro zone.
- Thank you, gentleman.
- Ain't no thang.
- Leroy-Heimer.
(fire crackling)
(high fives gently)
Oh, that's new.
Baron Schnitzel-Nazi.
- What's goin' on?
- Oh, hello.
I'll wait for you here.
There we go.
All right.
By the way, (clears throat)
are you, by chance,
related to the Jews from
Lauf Schnitzel-Nazis?
- Yes, I am.
(solemn music)
- How's your Aunt Freda?
- Aunt Freda?
(laughs) She is still fat?
- I don't recall her being fat.
(dramatic sound)
But, who looks like they
did in college, anyway,
am I right?
- Not me, not me.
Not me, not me, not me.
- Not this one.
- 'Cause I was...
I mean, you know what I'm
talkin' about? (laughs)
- Guten tag.
- (laughs) Oh, Gutenberg!
(car engine starting)
(solemn music)
(car door shuts)
(car drives away)
- (sighs thankfully) Man, that .
Whew!
We gotta get outta here, man!
We-
(cat toy jingling)
- He left the cat toy, man.
- Uh-uh.
- He left it.
(excitedly playing)
- Oh! (laughing manically)
- Well, all right, friends.
The first fight of the evenin'
will feature one of my slaves
versus one of the slaves
of my distinguished guest,
Mr. Jacob Dixon.
- (laughs) You know, Robert,
I hope you're as gracious a losr
as you are a host.
(both men laughing)
- All right,
enough talk.
(snaps fingers)
(gentle string music)
(men stumbling)
- (sighs) Now,
fight, you devils.
Fight to the death!
(man laughs evilly)
(pensive music)
(slapping skin)
- Hey.
Um, question?
- Mm-hmm.
- (laughs) How do we get
out of this thing alive?
- Um, it's really simple.
It's, just let me pretend to ki.
- Hmm.
Maybe it just makes more sense
if I pretend to kill you.
- Yeah...
I just, I want to make it belie.
So...
- No, that's what I was,
that's what I was going for, to.
- What the blazes is going on oe
in that endless clench?
Tear him apart!
- Okay.
(struggling sounds)
- Just, just,
just die from this.
- From this?
Um...
Uh, just, you know what?
Just, something doesn't feel ri.
So, if I can just,
if I can just,
let me,
go with me here.
- Oh, something...
(struggling sounds)
- Yup, that was it, that was it.
This feels much more real, so.
- Really? What? Why?
- Um, sorry,
what do you mean, "why"?
- Fight, my God!
(pensive music)
- Oh.
- I'm getting frustrated now.
- Damn it!
Kill!
- Oh. (clears throat)
(struggling sounds)
- Nope, not a thing, not a thin.
- Okay, I just get-
Mmm, I'm gonna get him.
I got him.
- Let me get you, though.
- Just let me get you, though.
- Nope, let me get you.
- No, let me get you.
It was my idea,
so can I do it first?
- Let me get you.
- Let me get you, though.
- Just for like a second.
Can you just let me get
you for a second, please?
I'll let you-
- Stop fighting like sissies
and kill each other!
- Okay, ready? I can do that.
- All right, ready?
(struggling sounds)
- So, just check this out.
- Yeah, all right.
- We'll back up,
and you run at me, real fast,
just do a bunch of spins,
and kicks of flourishes,
and I'll just knock ya out, one,
and then you're dead.
- Okay.
No, wait, wait.
- What?
- I'm sorry,
so you can look cool?
No thank you.
- If someone doesn't die soon,
I will kill you both.
- Thank you.
(yelling with effort)
(growling aggressively)
- Ah, that's my boy!
(yelling with effort)
(growling aggressively)
- You are not getting stronger
from my punches.
- Yes, I am though!
- Come here.
(slapping skin)
Listen, let's be fair, okay?
We both slam into each other
and we both die.
Fair?
- That's fair.
- Okay.
One!
- This'll be good.
- Two!
- Three!
(body slamming each other)
What?
- Oh, you son of a bitch.
- What? You were never gonna fa.
- You didn't even try
to fall down.
- What the Hell?
- You were never...
The fakest thing is you're...
You know what, there.
(slapping skin)
- No, don't hit me.
- Ow.
- What in tarnation
are you two doing?
- You hit my balls.
- Hey, everybody.
War's over.
(crickets chirping)
Slavery is abolished.
Sorry.
- (sighs frustratingly)
We'll call it a draw.
- Done.
- Good for you though, huh?
- Thank you?
- Let's go.
- Whoa, wait.
Before you...
No, no, no, no, no, no.
Hold up, hold up.
- Just if, just if we may,
if I may?
Who do you think would have won?
- Yeah, between the two of us?
- Contextualize the whole thing.
- They are a step ahead of us,
every single time.
(audience quiets)
(swooshing sound)
- Dicknanigans.
(mysterious music)
(cars honking)
(cars crashing)
(kicking sound effect)
- Whoa.
(dramatic music)
(audience chatting excitedly)
- Mm-hmm, mm-hmm.
- Dicknanigans.
- It's amazing.
(mysterious music continues)
- I know.
(casual music)
(buggy rattling)
(sits down in buggy)
(punches groin)
- Blurms!
(dramatic sound)
(audience chatting excitedly)
- Dicknanigans.
- It's dialogue without dialogu.
- Absolutely.
I feel like they're in my head.
(mysterious music ends)
(gentle piano music)
(gentle piano music continues)
(audience gasps)
(bouncing on one leg)
(kicks groin)
- Sigoing.
(dramatic sound)
(audience chatting excitedly)
(laughs in amazement) (claps ha)
- Dicknanigans.
- Wow.
(dramatic sound)
(kicks groin)
- Oohoo.
- Dicknanigans.
(kicks groin)
- Phrismus.
- Dicknanigans.
(kicks groin)
- Oh.
Glurl.
- Dicknanigans.
(kicks groin)
- Solange.
- Dicknanigans.
(ethereal tone)
- (gasps) Oh. (laughs happily)
(audience applauding)
(audience whistles)
(audience cheering)
(ethereal tones continue)
- (whistling) Gentlemen,
(puts slide on board)
exploded nut syndrome
is a condition indicated by
the presence of exploded nuts,
which yours are.
By the way,
I saw your show last night.
(clicks tongue) Amazing.
- [Speaker Phone] Dr. Kravitz,
you have a visitor in the main .
(dramatic music)
(heavy breathing)
- All right, listen up.
Sheriff's Deparment's close by,
we'll be safe there.
- Okay.
- Stay close.
I'll get you outta here.
(zombies attacking)
(men screaming)
- Oh shi-.
Oh my God,
they got Brad!
They got Brad!
- But, they didn't get us.
They didn't get us, okay?
We're still alive.
All right, keep it together.
- All right, yeah.
- We gotta make it to
that Sheriff Station.
- Okay. (breathing heavily)
Oh my God.
(zombies moaning)
(dramatic music)
- We gotta go through them.
Stay together,
keep movin',
and don't get bit.
Go.
(dramatic music intensifies)
(zombies moaning)
(breathing heavily)
(zombie moans)
Are you gettin' this?
- Yeah, what is up?
- All right, let's go, let's go.
(zombies moaning)
This is crazy.
- What?
- I don't know.
(dramatic music swells)
(door locks)
Ain't that some (beep).
- These are some racist
mother(beep) zombies!
- Why would you even lock the d?
I mean, the window's broken and-
(zombie grunts)
(gasps) Oh!
- Oh, Hell no.
Nah, nah, nah.
(dramatic music swells)
(zombie child growls)
Oh, come on.
- What is that?
- They seriously wouldn't let h.
- That's-
- Hey, guys.
Isn't this great?
(birds chirping)
These racist zombies are leavin.
Come on, we havin' a party.
(agreeable grunts)
(upbeat music)
The beer is here!
(everyone cheers)
And look who I brought!
Come on, man!
(everyone cheering)
(upbeat music continues)
(zombie struggling)
(jazzy intro music)
- Hey, Uncle Ted.
- Ah!
- Oh, jeez.
(Uncle Ted laughs)
Whew!
Sorry, Uncle Ted, man.
- Oh, jeez.
I got you, didn't I?
- Yeah, you got me, man.
You got me pretty good. (laughs)
- Oh.
- So, what's goin' on today?
- Oh, just the usual, young buc.
Just another day at the laundro.
Why, people come in,
they do their laundry,
we chat it up about some
of the topics of the day.
(laughs) That's just another da,
hangin' at the 'mat.
(distant laughter)
(feel good music)
♪ Choo, choo ♪
- I wonder what's goin' on
in the barber shop today.
Sure looks like they
havin' fun over there.
(gentle saxophone music)
(pats back)
- Forget all that, Keith!
Come on,
we got our own assortment
of colorful characters
right here in the 'mat!
Come on.
Hey there, you need any more qu?
- Nope.
- (laughs) Okay, okay.
Hilarious.
Oh!
Hey there, Miss Demetrius,
you need some more quarters?
Oh, she didn't hear me.
- That's part of the problem, U.
You know,
all that noise up in here
from the machines running
and it's kinda hot.
- Loud and hot!
Sound like my old lady!
(gentle saxophone music continu)
(distant laughter)
(feel good music)
♪ Choo, choo ♪
- Billy Dee Williams is in ther.
He's Lando Calrissian,
he runs Cloud City.
- Oh, (laughs) yeah, baby!
- All right! (laughs)
(gentle saxophone music)
- Damn it, Keith!
What'd I tell you?
We got it goin' on,
right here at the 'mat, baby!
- Uncle Ted, I gotta tell you s.
(gentle saxophone music continu)
I got my own washer and dryer m.
I just keep hanging out here
'cause I didn't want you to fee.
- Oh, you didn't want me
to feel bad, huh? (laughs)
Got you're own washer
and dryer, all right.
Oh, you're big timing
me now, okay. (laughs)
I see how it is.
Hey, well your shirt ain't clea,
your pants ain't clean.
(laughs) You can't get a good wh
on one of them home washer dry-
- Uncle Ted,
I'm going.
- No, no, no,
wait, wait, wait, wait, wait.
Let's have some fun.
Let's have some fun!
You could get in one of the laus
and I could push you around!
- No.
I'm outta here.
(gentle saxophone music continu)
- Wait, wait, wait, wait.
Hold on there, then, Keith.
Keith!
- If that don't work,
then you can do a little tap da.
And then you go,
"I'm your man." (laughs)
(keys dropping)
Hey, welcome to the
barber shop, young man.
- You're Billy Dee Williams.
- Yeah, yeah.
How you doin'?
- I'm good. Thank you so much, .
- Could you do me a favor?
- Yeah.
- Could you let go of my hand?
- Oh.
(everyone laughs)
(gentle saxophone music)
Oh, thanks, man!
(gentle saxophone music fades)
(feel good music)
♪ Choo, choo ♪
♪ Baby, the funky train's comin♪
- Good morning, ladies and gent,
we are about to begin boarding
South Northern Airlines,
flight 34, to Grand Rapids.
- Okay, excuse me.
Boarding group one.
I'm in boarding group one, excu.
I'm in boarding group one.
- And we would like to begin prg
with out first class passengers.
First class passengers only, pl.
(passengers shuffling)
Next, our business class
passengers may now board.
(scanning tickets)
Okay, now, we would like to wele
our Regal Alliance Elite member.
Regal Alliance Elite members.
(scanning tickets)
Okay, now, all passengers with .
- Okay.
- Anyone with a small children,
you may board now.
(baby noises)
Okay, we would like to continueg
with uniformed military personn.
- What?
Why, this is...
Thank you for your service.
Thank you so much for your serv.
God bless you.
- Thank you for your service.
Thank you for your service.
All right, people in wheelchair.
(wheel chair rolling)
Any priests, nuns, rabbis, imam.
- What?
Why do they get special treatme?
- As-Salaam-Alaikum.
- I've never-
(nun shoves by)
That's typical.
- Any old people in
wheelchairs with babies.
(baby crying)
Any old religious people
with military babies.
- What's a military-
- Thank you for your service.
(tickets scanning)
Jason Schwartzman.
(scans ticket)
Anyone with a blue suitcase,
you may now board.
- Finally.
- No, not you, sir.
- Not me?
This is a blue suitcase.
- That's a blue computer bag.
- So you're not, you're not
going to let me on then?
(tickets scanning)
(speaker phone in background)
(sips drink)
- Damn it!
Damn it, damn it, damn
it, damn it, damn it!
God damn it!
- Anyone who doesn't seem crank.
(everyone shuffles by)
- Drunk people,
we will now be boarding any dru.
Drunk people may board.
(drunk knocks passenger over)
- All right.
Nope, it's my bad.
Sir.
(men struggling)
(knocks over barrier)
(paper rustles)
(phone rings)
- Ooo.
(answers phone)
Hello?
Oh, hey, Christian.
Yeah.
Totally.
Well, you have your favorites
and I have my favorites.
(laughs) Okay.
Call you later.
Ciao, ciao.
(paper rustles)
(hangs up phone)
Boarding group one.
(momentous music)
- Anybody seen Jason Schwartzma!
- Jason Schwartzman!
- Reach up your hand,
we're gonna find you!
Jason!
- Jason Schwartzman!
- I got him!
I got Schwartzman here!
- Hey, everyone!
Jason Schwartzman's fine!
(everyone cheers)
- We've got Jason Schwartzman,
let's wrap it up, people!
- Boarding group one over here!
Got a boarding group one.
Ah!
(feel good music)
♪ All I want, yeah ♪
♪ But I don't need you ♪